do you trust your gut imagine you've
been saving up money for a while so you
visit the bank ready to make your first
major investment you talk with an
advisor and after a few minutes they
tell you about a plan that you feel is
extremely risky you ask them why and
they just say they have a good feeling
about it would you feel safe
of course not which is why we use data
strategies this is simply an
understanding of our personal objectives
collecting data and then managing and
analyzing it to ensure that it aligns
with these objectives gone are the days
of Simply trusting your gut today
businesses work with data analysts
engineers and scientists to form these
data strategies leading to better
outcomes so by understanding them you
can position yourself for success and
make a meaningful contribution to the
world of data and analytics and even in
your personal life to learn more about
all things data head on over to the data
differentiator IBM's guide for data
leaders and enthusiasts alike we hope to
see you there